probably hurt Washington Times the
peanutter and Fox News contributor as
well as Mike Davis Fondren president of
the article 3 project gentlemen good to
see you both Charlie I'm going to come
to you first I'm looking at the FBI
Charlie and I've lost all hope right I
don't think they're going to investigate
Joe and Hunter Biden so as Americans if
we want the truth do we have to look to
James culmer in the house by the way who
are not well equipped to investigate
crimes like this but is that the only
hope we have of getting to the truth in
regard to the criminal Enterprise of Joe
and Hunter Biden
well I think that uh that's probably our
best hope at the moment uh as as well as
a few enterprising reporters who are
doing their Duty and actually trying to
get to the bottom of this because not
only has the FBI completely walked off
the field and left uh all of these
incredible questions and obvious uh you
know examples of crimes that have
apparently occurred uh uninvestigated
but the entire media has completely
walked away and has lost all interest in
doing their job they're far more
interested in you know you know the
coverage of former president who's no
longer in office uh that they won't uh
begin to investigate the obvious
questions the obvious I mean you you
can't it's it's impossible to you have
to knowingly decide you don't want to
know the answers to these questions to
not try to get to the bottom of some of
them there's so such glaring examples of
corruption and you make a national name
for yourself if you actually break a
story like this that everyone else
rejected I mean you're almost a national
hero if you will but Mike Newsweek is
now reporting that Devin Archer Hunter
Biden's former business partner and
former barisma board member he is in
talks with Republicans on the oversight
committee to come in and testify Mike
this could completely blow the case open
if he decides to flip on Hunter Biden
they better put Devin archer in the
witness protection program because I'm
telling you what the FBI has had
evidence since at least
2017 that then Vice President Joe Biden
and his sleazebag son Hunter took a 10
million dollar foreign bribe from
Barista and changed American policy
threatened the Ukrainian presidents that
if he didn't fire that Ukrainian
prosecutor investigating berezma and the
bidens Ukraine was going to lose a
billion dollars in USA that is the
allegation there are 17 audio recordings
apparently at the FBI 15 with Hunter and
two with then Vice President Joe Biden
so this evidence is coming out what does
the Biden justice department do they
indict Trump for the non-crime of having
his presidential records They indict
Trump for getting into a fight with
Librarians and other bureaucrats for
overdue library books that apparently
they claimed Trump didn't check out
properly as really good point we're
fighting over librarian and checked out
books but but Charlie your view on this
because again if Devin Archer flips or
if we have these 17 tapes that allegedly
barisma has the FBI can Stonewall all
they want to cover up for Joe Biden but
this information is going to come to the
house and get to the public and Joe
Biden may not be able to hide it any
longer yeah
and and by the way I I think it actually
is probably a healthy thing for this to
to be exposed in the house uh simply
because it means that uh it informs the
public since the the media refuses to
even try to do its job it informs the
public and allows the public to make a
decision in the next election which is
how I want to see all this end I want to
see all this end by Joe Biden getting
thrown out of office for being the most
corrupt president to ever hold office
but Mike also makes a really important
point that a lot of people have sort of
glossed over the the the carrot in this
whole bribery scheme in which the Biden
family apparently got paid 10 million
dollars was one billion dollars in U.S
American Aid going to Ukraine that was
the carrot that the Biden Administration
was using in order to protect their uh
corrupt cronies in at barisma in in
Ukraine and so the question is you know
what was that one billion dollars for
was that one billion dollars simply
money that Joe Biden came up with in
order to to to execute this bribery this
is a massive Scandal involving U.S tax
dollars uh in order to uh uh enrich the
Biden family and uh and sell out
American foreign policy no doubt about
that and again in this Hunter Biden Joe
Biden Saga there continues to be cracks
because
um Hunter Biden was deposed today in the
Arkansas child support case over his
four-year-old daughter as Jonathan truly
pointed out it's not clear if Hunter has
previously gone under oath about his
finances so Mike this actually could be
a problem for him and this court this
mother of his child that was born out of
wedlock maybe the Avenue in which we get
the the details of the finances of the
Biden corruption scheme
this is why Hunter Biden is so stupid he
wants to fight over child support and
expose his entire foreign corruption
scheme the D.C uh the D.C based FBI or
the delaware-based uh FBI and justice
department May ignore his crimes but I I
seriously doubt that the Arkansas
prosecutors in Arkansas courts are going
to ignore perjury before the courts it's
starting to get hot gentlemen very hot
for the bidens yeah Charlie and Mike
thanks for joining me appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else